hey guys Pete here the eighth episode of
mr. robot season 2 has come and gone and
there's a lot to talk about
this will be my mr. robot season 2
episode 8 recap and review and will
contain spoilers for everything that's
happened in the show up to this point
episode 8 starts with a flashback to
when Mobley and Trenton first met
they're both of the same copy shop
thinking they're waiting to meet Elliot
and Mobley sheepishly tries to make
small talk with her at first I thought
they were at this at that coffee shop
where Elliot took down the owner in
season 1 but as they talked it was
revealed that there's another one that
has really fast internet which would be
the one that he was at she tricks him
into visiting a benchmarking site she
gives him the address for and she gets
control of his phone just as Darlene
shows up Darlene sits down and points
out what Trenton did and then tells them
that Elliot couldn't make it she tells
him he wrote something in which she
reads it says what I'm about to tell you
is top secret conspiracy bigger than all
of us there is a powerful group of
people out there who that are secretly
running the world I'm talking about the
guys no one knows about the guys that
are invisible the top 1% of the 1% it
fades out to the title credits and then
we see Darlene and present time back at
madame executioner's Mowgli is at a
laptop with Trenton and Cisco looking
over his shoulder Darlene wants to know
what's going on and she learns that they
found out there's gonna be a conference
call about operation Berenstain the next
day they get on the call and record the
whole thing but the only thing we really
learn is that at first is that it's on
the 4th of July they decided to make a
video to expose the call and while
they're taping the first time the tape
gets messed up and Darlene exposes her
face to the camera they finish up and
Trenton uploads the video that is meant
to expose the FBI and put them on notice
Mosley's listening to the call again so
we learn that they are they were looking
at 16 suspects originally but now
there's only 15 because we can assume
that one of them being Romero is
actually dead he tries to leave but
Cisco stops him and they go back and
forth about the dark army before they
can finish the conversation madam
executioner walks up the steps and
catches them all by surprise we find
Angela in a karaoke bar with a guy who I
thought was one the one-night-stand
from earlier in the season she was at a
bar with the lawyer and she went home
with him we learned that they're
actually dating and she's watching that
society beta the video which prompts him
to
like why is it more interesting than a
date she seems drunk and generally down
which I guess might be related to the
talk she had with DOM she never answers
the guy about the video and instead
excuses herself to get go get another
drink on the way a friend of her dad
stops her for a conversation that turns
into a heated exchange he talks [ __ ]
about her working for the company that
killed her mother and she responds by
destroying him for being a lifelong
plumber she basically says that that's
the best you could come up with and
mentions that she's 27 with a six-figure
salary and that she's just getting
started we find f Society zip tying
Susan Jacobs to a trailing in her pull
room they head downstairs to try to
figure out what they're gonna do she
keeps screaming so Darlene sends Trenton
to go shut her up
Susan tells her that she needs to use
the bathroom and convinces her to cut
her loose of course she struggles to get
away but then ends up smashing her head
into the wall and knocking herself out
when she tries to charge Trenton she
goes back to the others and Darlene says
they need to tie her back up until they
can own her so that they know that she
won't talk we're here Angela singing
everyone wants to rule the world in the
background as they try to find something
in Susan's phone and laptop they don't
find much in the accounts attached to
her phone but we do see that she has a
pacemaker due to several emails from
doctors they find out she has a yahoo
email account that isn't hooked up to
the phone and while they're looking and
talking about strategies to get in
Trenton comes back from her office with
a post-it note containing the info begin
a shot of Darlene whose deep in thought
and hear Cisco say even if we do find
something what then Angela finishes up
her Tears for Fears cover and heads to
the bar there's a businessman in tight
there who tells her that he loves that
song yes sure if she really has desire
to rule the world and she replies with
my desires go way beyond that he moves
in to pay tries to excuse himself but we
get the idea that she talks him into
staying we get our first glimpse of Dom
who was interviewing the financial guy
Darlene was sleeping with aka the guy
she took the gun that ended up in the
popcorn machine from she explains that
she found the casing that leads right
back to his gun and emphasizes that he
had it illegally in the city she has him
in a tough spot so she offers immunity
for a name we don't get to find out what
he does as the scene ends with him
thinking Darlene comes back into the
pool room carrying a Taser
she cuts a Susan loose
her cigarette and agrees that her wound
looks pretty bad as they're smoking
Darlene that's her note that they found
some good stuff on her that they have
they can use to blackmail her but then
she also says that she knows that she'd
probably just slime her way out of it
she lets her know about her dad and that
she remembers seeing her on the TV when
she was just four years old they talked
a little more and then Darlene zaps her
with the stun gun in the heart which
knocks her into the pool unconscious
Darlene isn't unaffected by it but it's
clear that she intends to let her drown
it also seems like she was it was her
plan from the time she entered the room
when she tells everyone else she makes
it out like madam executioner freaked
out and that she was just trying to stop
her Mobley points out that she had a
heart condition and can't believe that
Darlene didn't see those emails she
tells Mowgli and Trenton that they can
leave and that her and Cisco will wipe
things down and figure out what to do
the two of them take off Darlene and
Cisco set up an auto-reply for her email
and then the scene ends Mowgli and
Trenton are sitting on the train
platform talking about what to do
Trenton says it must have been
self-defense but Mobley doesn't look
sure she asked him what the plan is and
he says well we can't stay here
he points out that they don't know who
will be waiting for them at home the
dark army the FBI or the cops Darlene
and Cisco are talking about their
options and she says they need to take
care of it because she doesn't trust
Cisco's guys she's also worried that the
other people who went to DC for the
bailout but the other fsociety people
are gonna return so they can't just
leave the body
she says they need to do what they
always do when they go in full wipe down
mode after doing a hat they end up
loading the body into a giant duffel bag
and head to see the guy at the pound who
has access to the incinerator the guy
says he needs double because of the fact
that they let all the dogs go the last
time and he almost got fired so Darlene
offers to pay him an equine we find out
that she stole it from Susan and after a
struggle they load her body into the
furnace they take the train in Darlene
says she didn't think she was capable of
doing that she admits though that she
isn't feeling bad because she knew she
like she always knew she wanted to get
back at Susan for what happened to her
dad Cisco tries to comfort her by
telling her she's probably just in shock
if I mobely outside of his apartment
looking totally sketched out he paid a
delivery guy to go check his apartment
for him before he decides to go in which
he tried at home with her
father who she asked if he ever thought
moving out of the city as he's telling
her they can't do that she hears a sound
outside she goes outside the check and
sees a suspicious-looking car creeping
down her street
Mobley enters this place 2pac and we
hear someone knocking on the door almost
right away as he looks out the window he
sees a bunch of SUVs and we hear them
saying to open up it's the FBI
Dom comes in to interview him and lays
out some of what they know about Romero
Mobley never says anything and just
listens while she tells him he could be
a big help in solving the case she tells
him how she went to visit Romero's
mother after the murder and shows him
the flyer from the end of the world
party that she found she breaks down how
she used it to find a fanpage he made
like way back in 2003 for this DJ and
that he was actually the only person who
ever created anything related to the guy
this led her to believe that this was
how he came up with this hacker handle
but she tells him that she doesn't
really care because what she really
wants his tyrell wellick he listens to
her spiel and then asked for a lawyer
I'm talking to her boss who reminds her
that they are trying to work from the
top down
she says he can be useful and he reminds
her about the shitstorm they're facing
because of the conference call League he
tells her whatever paranoia she is
putting him in is done from just picking
him up and that she needs to cut him
loose because they don't have anything
on Mobley gets out and sends Trenton
self destructing text that telling her
that they are burned he tells her to
meet him in the same place they met for
the first time and then wipes the phone
and drops it in a bike messengers basket
she gets the message impacts her stuff
and we see him duck into a train station
back at the FBI Dom is looking at the
video file and we see the guy Angela was
dating is actually working with the FBI
he's telling her that Angela ditched him
for the old guy at the bar and he seems
broken up about the way that it happened
no way to tell if she figured out
something was off about him or if she
was just drunk and decided to be done
with it it talked some more about how
the video is blowing up in their face
before the scene cuts away we find our
lean back at Cisco's place sleeping when
she wakes up he's already in the shower
and she noticed his laptop is out but
the screens still lit up like he was
just using it was he turned into coffee
shop and learned that Mobley is over two
hours late scene jumps back and forth
and we see Darlene has gotten into
Cisco's laptops
picture of herself sleeping and we get
some subtitles of the Chinese he tells
them that he has Darlene and they say
good job with the femtocell that the
back door is in play
they also say stage 2 is ready to begin
and I don't really know if Darlene can
read this stuff or not obviously Cisco
speaks Chinese in some scenes but not
sure why he knows how to or if that
means Darlene does as well we get one
more shot of Trenton staring towards the
door and hear it open and then it cuts
back to Darlene who is now leaning
against the wall
Cisco comes out of the bathroom he sees
that she's destroyed his laptop and the
episode ends with her getting ready to
smash him with the baseball bat so it's
a pretty good episode as far as things
moving along with the story kind of
strange at the same time since we didn't
have any Elliot sightings at all not a
lot of mystery happening since the FBI
FBI is closing in and you know Susan
Jacobs coming back and made for like a
situation that they had to deal with
head-on an important thing we learned is
that they're still focused on Tyrell but
Mobley and the gun owner getting pulled
in is going to lead to some problems
also we know that they were paying
attention to Angela from well before the
scene where dawn came up to confront her
at her cubicle
so no Elliot no price no Johanna no Rey
and no direct whiterose although those
conversations might have been with him
on the computer Tom seems to be feeling
the pressure and the video took things
up a notch feel like there was some
foreshadowing with that VHS tape messin
up I mean we didn't see them white madam
executioner's place down but I assume
they did that before they went to the
pound the tape just stood out as a
possible loose in eventually someone
will realize that susan has disappeared
but they probably should have a little
bit of time so let me know what you
think in the comments I liked the
episode but it seemed like it flew by
and I realized after it was over that
since we didn't see so many characters
that it built up a lot of anticipation
for next week what do you think is gonna
happen when Elliot gets out to find out
what just all went down like do you
think they'll even tell him about Susan
or I don't even know what is the dark
army mean when they say stage two like I
know he had a little bit of a talk with
you know White Rose in the past on that
but it wasn't really clear if I remember
and what the hell is Darlene gonna do
with Cisco now that she beat him down
with the bat it's a lot I don't know
please like the video if you found it
interesting and please subscribe to my
channel I try to put out a recap and
review as soon as
right after the episode airs thanks for
watching I will talk to you soon